elle se prépare depuis deux bonnes
soeurs car dans le camping et soirée du
lundi sont dignes de side d'un samedi
soir mais je préfère coiffer fc le
maquillage pour que le maquillage parce
que j'aime gbagbo a fait est que cela
fait du camping
elles sont les stars de l'adulte
opportunités vabre certains points
français design franchement ça déchire
ya rien eu c'est pour que pour les
jeunes franchement y'a rien a dit je
vous conseille à tous de venir
les bagues ça craque pour vous 10
campeurs et animateurs se croisent les
pubs et costumes ont fait ce qu'il a pu
relaxe maintenant on est star d'un soir
ont flashé sur les nuits du camping on
vient vraiment folle animations à ce qui
l'est c'est que pour les jeunes c'est
bien parce qu'on peut s'amuser en
journée et en soirée ont fait le
spectacle en situant les discothèques
derrière donc pour les jeunes veulent
bouger sans forcément sortir ce n'est
pas la voiture
tout n'est pas noir
il
mais pour ceux qui ont encore un peu de
force
la nuit n'est pas terminée c'est la puce
il sort en boîte un vous ai jamais vu
même avec les bibittes le beurre et les
meilleures boîtes par an grâce au fond
ce qui par
reg brockville club à tapantes musique
on pense qu'on appelle et chris lines et
à perles musicales ur et apprend
m'aventure du doubs la musique du soleil
g